if you clicked on this video which let's
be honest you probably did then you
probably fall into one of a few
different camps perhaps you're someone
who's currently feeling out of shape
maybe experiencing poor mobility and
some pain your goal therefore might be
to start moving in a healthier and more
functional manner through training
another option is that you're someone
who is currently in great shape but with
some areas missing maybe you're very
strong and work out regularly but get
winded climbing the stairs or maybe you
have great cardio but you've noticed
that you can't bend over and touch your
toes perhaps in that case you want to
learn a little bit about functional
training so as to prevent any further
deterioration to ensure that you
continue to be able to move well or
maybe it's that you want to be able to
do something else cool like a handstand
finally you might be here because you
hate functional fitness and you want to
make fun of just how much you don't need
it I'm going to attempt to address all
of you in this
video so what is functional fitness
first of all we need to Define
functional fitness so that we can you
know do it the critics will tell you
that every movement has a purpose curls
are useful for building big biceps and
if that's what you want then that's your
function more to the point every
exercise makes you stronger even curls
and that's functional so if every
exercise is functional then the whole
concept of functional fitness is
redundant it's nonsense bodybuilding is
functional fitness powerlifting is
functional fitness just focus on getting
stronger this idea is based on a
fundamental understanding of the entire
concept every exercise builds your body
so does that make bodybuilding nonsense
most lifts involve some power so is
every exercise
powerlifting you can be a bodybuilder
without ever doing a curl or a squat
that's because bodybuilding isn't really
about the individual exercises but
rather the goals of the training and the
programming that exists to accomplish
those goals and the same is true for
functional fitness functional fitness
means training in order to accomplish a
specific goal a specific function if
you're an athlete that means sprinting
drills and explosiveness for jumping if
you're a martial artist you probably
need conditioning and core strength
there's no conspiracy here and the only
reason we don't call bodybuilding or
powerlifting functional fitness is
because they're the training and the
goal of the same thing you don't train
to become better at powerlifting you
powerlift to become better at
powerlifting but if you're not an
athlete then functional training has to
mean something else it might mean
training to be better Suited to Everyday
Life to move better and feel better and
to prevent injury and decline so that
you're stronger in every movement or
maybe it means you want to be able to do
cool
to use the example of the bicep
curl yes bicep curls are perfectly
functional but the question is what else
are you doing and why a functional
training program can include bicep curls
in fact nearly all of my programs
include bicep curls but the question is
what what else are you doing and why for
the most part functional training for
the non-athlete means addressing things
that are often overlooked and that can
often creep up on you and become
damaging deficits especially as you get
older or it's things you overlook that
prevent you from doing cool stuff so if
you're a bodybuilder or powerlifter I
might ask you do you do anything to
train your rotational strength this is
an important movement pattern that often
goes overlooked and that builds strength
for activities like wrestling and cool
moves like one-armed push-ups it also
helps to strengthen the back against
injury when moving in this plane say
when pulling an awkward piece of
furniture out from against the wall I'm
not saying you can't train and not train
your rotational strength almost all of
us Overlook some aspects of our strength
but that's the difference between
something like bodybuilding or strength
training and functional training which
focuses on doing those things that you
might need and otherwise get
overlooked now some people might tell me
that you'll you will never need to push
or pull that much weight in the
rotational plane well firstly you might
secondly you also never need to deadlift
100 kg off the ground doesn't mean it's
not good at building stability and
preventing injury doesn't mean it won't
make you better at also lifting 20 kg
off the ground and know you can't just
Squat and deadlift and assume rotational
strength will take care of itself just
like squatting doesn't make your bench
press stronger this is called the law of
specificity it basically means you need
to train for the movement pattern trait
or attribute you actually you
want in other words if you never train
your rotational plane you probably
aren't very strong in that movement
pattern and other areas are equally
important if not more important you
might think it's okay to ignore shoulder
Mobility indefinitely but when you're
walking around with a hunch at the age
of 50 and can't scratch your own back
you may wish You' done something about
this sooner same if you start
experiencing serious stica due to tight
hips likewise you're going to need
shoulder ability if you want to start
doing
handstands another big one is cardio if
you only focus on strength and have zero
cardio then you aren't doing functional
training if you getting winded on the
way up the stairs you could stand to be
a little more functional if that's
important to you for you making your
training more functional might be as
simple as adding cardio into the mix why
do people get so irate about this here's
the thing though doing this might make
you a little less strong it might mean
you lose some muscle size if Aesthetics
are your goal now you have less time to
dedicate to lifting you're more fatigued
and you're adding a form of training
that makes you more
catabolic but that's the idea behind
functional training and that's okay
that's changing your training goals to
focus on all around function that's the
difference between powerlifting
bodybuilding and functional
fitness likewise a functional trainee
might intentionally opt to drop out of
things like extremely heavy squats if
you're currently squatting 150 kg then
adding more weight to that squat might
not benefit you that much outside the
gym especially because you can't get
that much weight onto your back to
perform that way in the real world
anyways your efforts might be better
focused elsewhere so that's functional
training how do you get started if you
have an obvious issue that you'd like to
address then this is easy you simply
research the problem you're having find
various ways to strengthen that area and
address the issue and add that training
into your current regime there you go
your training is now more
functional if you want to apply
functional training more broadly you
simply look at the aspects of your own
strength and fitness that are missing
and add them back in the extent to which
you do this will likely depend on your
personal preferences and goals as for
specific moves and forms of training
well everyone's different what's useful
for everyone what interests each
individual will vary but fortunately for
starting out there are some common
concerns that affect a lot of people and
these can provide a good starting point
for this discussion here are some areas
to
consider
cardio shoulder Mobility pelvic
alignment core stability weak glutes hip
mobility grip strength gate and running
form rotational strength ankle Mobility
hip flexor strength balance
explosiveness single leg strength
frontal plane training I.E side to
side straight arm strength ankle
stiffness tendon strength scapular
control strength endurance such as
lifting something heavy a lot of times
propri reception and this is by no means
a comprehensive
list as you can see then functional
training isn't some conspiracy and it
certainly has its place among the
pantheon of workout Trends to begin ask
yourself what's missing from your
training make sure you're training all
the major planes of motion sagittal
frontal and rotational make sure you're
including the major movement patterns a
horizontal push and pull hip hinge squat
rotation gate
Etc include variation to prepare
yourself for more unpredictable angles
to tools like kettle bells and
activities like trail running and
movement training are perfect for
this make sure you're addressing the
pillars of Fitness strength Mobility
endurance explosiveness write yourself a
program that addresses all these equally
not necessarily to the fullest capacity
you're capable of in any area but that
spreads that energy across the board and
you're on your way to a very functional
routine and if you want to go that extra
mile I also recommend looking at your
lifestyle outside of the gym and how
that's impacting on your functional
fitness if you spend all day sitting
you'll not only be damaging your posture
and Mobility but will also be
squandering your cardiovascular fitness
try and move more throughout your day
and try to move more
healthily one great way to do that is
with today's sponsor Vivo Barefoot Vivo
Barefoot makes functional Footwear that
more closely mimics the way our feet are
supposed to work when bare a wider toe
Box gives you greater surface area to
balance on but also means your toes
won't become crank cramped and crushed
together a small heel means you aren't
walking around with shortened tight
carves and can properly produce power
through full plantar flexion against the
ground it also makes movements like the
squat far more of a Mobility Challenge
and that's just scratching the
surface and VI Barefoot make what are in
my opinion the best minimal shoes out
there they have a huge variety of
designs that genuinely all look really
cool they're extremely comfortable to
the point of feeling like slippers they
last for ages and they're sustainably
produced they've also been consistent
stly brilliant to work with not that
that really affects you in any way if
you fancy grabbing yourself a pair make
sure to use the link below and code
bioner 15 to get 15% off your first
order and that my friends is functional
training in a nutshell let me know your
thoughts in the comments below has that
cleared anything up for you when did you
make the switch to functional training
of course if you want to start with
functional and super functional training
right now you can check out my ebook and
training program superfunctional
training 2.0 it comes with over 2 hours
of instructional video and an 80 plus
page ebook it provides full programs and
explanations to help you build your body
in every capacity and to go beyond what
you need to perform optimally in a wide
range of scenarios there's a link in the
description down below and because I
wanted to encourage new people to try
out functional training and to reward
you guys who watch at the very end
there's currently a code on that will
get you 10% off of your copy that's
starting 10 either way guys thank you so
much for watching this one and I'll see
you next time bye for
now